my name is Dr Patty gibink I've been a
board-certified obstetrician
gynecologist for over 25 years and I've
completed thousands of abortions today
I'm going to describe induction
abortions generally done from 22 weeks
to term at 39 weeks because the child is
so large and developed an abortion
procedure at this point takes two to
three days to complete and due to the
risks and the need for monitoring this
procedure is generally done in the
hospital or a Surgery Center
specifically about miffapristone which
is an abortion pill this pill is
available like widely through pharmacies
in America and you in first and second
trimesters you take you take the pill at
home so this is an at-home abortion and
then what you [__] the baby out yes yes
that's crazy I didn't know that was a
thing so there are so in the U.S normal
year there's about 620 000 abortions
that we know of uh more about 53 of
those are medical abortions with pills
so that is over 300 000 babies that are
literally being flushed down the toilet
with our sewage it's Unthinkable it is
Unthinkable wouldn't that clog the
toilet in 2020 well they're small like
it comes out it breaks the baby apart so
a first trimester it's very small so
it's just little parts and it looks more
like blood clots but you know in 2020
there were over 900 000 abortions in the
U.S
so that's a half a million babies
flushed down toilets like like a literal
turd and this is how we treat life in
this country go ahead let's go I can't I
have I I'm so sorry I said this is yeah
I know I know you get nervous you laugh
a little when you get a little weirded
out and I get that I've done that since
I was little since you were little I
know you don't think it's funny the
teachers used to get mad at me because I
would always smile when they were
yelling at me I know I was in the I had
a lot of meetings about it I know all
about it I was in the place but the good
thing is the Liberals cancel people and
they like abortions so if they saw me
smiling they couldn't even cancel me
yeah they just like me they'll be like
look he finds joy in Flushing babies
down toilets so do we so do we oh we
love this boy he's so handsome so this
is for third trimester ones which the
pill taking the pill it becomes
dangerous so you have to do it under the
care of a doctor so here we go we sit
down today to film and my mom goes we're
watching this video just pull it up and
start filming start recording yeah I
didn't even give him any preview on it
oh my God I'm
blocks the pregnancy hormone
progesterone causing the lining of the
uterus to degenerate starving the fetus
of vital nutrients and oxygen if a
pristine alone doesn't necessarily kill
the fetus so fetal demise is often
induced beforehand this is often only
done for babies 20 weeks or older a
syringe with a large needle is filled
with a drug called digoxin digoxin is
used to treat heart problems
digoxin will cause fetal Cardiac Arrest
this is important a long needle is
inserted through the woman's abdomen or
vagina and the digoxin is injected into
the fluid surrounding the fetus under
ultrasound guidance poisoning the fetus
doesn't die immediately which is why
this is normally done one or two days
beforehand for the drug to be more
effective the abortion doctor can also
inject the digoxin directly into the
fetus targeting either the body heart or
umbilical vein potassium chloride can
also be be used to induce fetal demise
more immediately the fetus usually dies
within 24 hours of the injection of
digoxin if the fetus doesn't die within
24 hours the injection can be repeated
death is normally confirmed by
ultrasound before the start of delivery
on day two 24 to 36 hours after the
miffapristone the woman is given
misoprostol either orally or vaginally
causing her to go into labor the
misoprostol dose can be repeated every
three hours up to five times
usually after 24 hours of starting the
misoprostol the woman will vaginally
deliver the fetus if the woman is having
trouble delivering she may be given a
synthetic hormone called pitocin to
promote labor
once the fetus and the placenta have
been delivered and the bleeding is under
control the abortion is complete
complication rates increase as the fetus
grows the major complication from
induced abortion is incomplete abortion
in which pieces of the fetus and
placenta are left behind this requires
surgical intervention
other complications include cervical
laceration infection Hemorrhage uterine
rupture and even death future
pregnancies are also at a greater risk
for loss or premature delivery due to
abortion related trauma including injury
to the cervix the women you know that
got abortions they all were like like
extremely depressed because of it right
yeah it was extremely difficult and
traumatically I don't see how you even
like recover from that as like a woman
like I feel like that's just like it's
game changing like everything else
that's horrible and traumatic you pick
yourself up and you just keep going yeah
but that's you doing it it's hard so
that's a different level of guilt it is
especially when you're older and you
have perspective and you realize that
you know you could have made you could I
couldn't imagine a woman who had an
abortion watching this I haven't [__]
I feel bad and I'm not even out here
getting abortions but the thing is these
the pro-choice Advocates will tell you
this is women's rights this is Health
Care this is life-saving the you know
abortion is essential it's a right a
human right to take another human life
so they're using all these lofty words
uh they say that it's it's racist to not
allow abortions I mean they just say
whatever they want to get these these
this [__] Cloud around it that
really is covering up what's really
happening and people need to see this
people need to know that this is what is
happening this is going on as we speak
crazy somebody is poisoning a baby with
a needle in its mother's belly and the
mother is agreeing to it what Have We
Become just finish this up purpose of an
elective abortion is to ensure the
delivery of a dead fetus on the other
hand if a baby is wanted and the
mother's health is in danger the
obstetrician induces labor or does a
C-section and will have a neonatal
specialist present to take care of the
baby as I mentioned at the beginning I
used to perform abortions
at the time I truly believed I was
helping women Over time however I
realized that abortion doesn't just end
a pregnancy it ends the life of an
innocent unique human being as I cared
for women in my OB GYN practice I also
learned how abortion harms women I
stopped doing abortions and I became a
pro-life Advocate I am proof that anyone
can change no matter who they are or
what they have done I invite you to join
me and make a decision to protect the
pre-born thank you for watching
[__]
a bit [__] if you ask me but yeah it's
that and that's this that's the that's
why I want people to see it because yeah
that video what did we what did it get
for we watched it like twenty thousand
thirty thousand thirty thousand views no
everybody needs to see that and
everybody and if you have people see
that and still say that they believe
that it's okay separate yourselves from
those people because they're dark and
lost and maybe Jesus can save them but I
I I don't want to be around people that
can look this in the face and still be
okay with it what a great way to start
off filming Mom thank you I want to
watch some South Park or something some
boxing what cheers you up you know I
like some hockey fights I don't know man
just
this is why I don't let you pick the
videos you pick some [__] like this I
don't always pick [__] like this I
always pick you always pick some dumb
[__] the American Girl video I picked up
oh you picked one video that one was
good I've picked other videos he doesn't
let me pick he thinks he knows
everything because he's 19. yeah yeah
yeah I know what are you gonna do yeah
you know you know everything
oh I don't know [__] and that's the
difference once you realize that you
don't know jack [__] then the world
becomes your oyster and you start
learning all the things that you don't
know and you don't get cocky but you
know we're working on we're working on
them the whole family we're gonna make
sure we don't let Sonny become a cocky
schmuck we love you
okay let's wrap it up let's watch
something upbeat now okay because this
is heavy bought some MILF manure oh God
disco mommy definitely had a lot of
these
all right see you later
[Music]